welcome to the latest episode of this
just getting started about the voices of
the national football league already
we've had al michaels and we've had joe
buck of nbc sports and fox sports
respectively tell us about how their
careers in broadcasting just got started
and also some neat stories along the way
leading to a great piece of advice that
they've received in their careers that
maybe you can use in your life to take
with you
as you go about your journey here in
these crazy crazy times my guest this
week
from uh right here uh the cumulus
podcast network is home to just getting
started also to westwood one radio and
westwood one sports the voice of monday
night football on westwood one also you
hear him on cbs and the nba on tnt the
great kevin harlan rich thank you so
much great to be on i'm
over the moon in terms of working with
you so excited and uh it's gonna be a
very fun season the longest we've had
two which is gonna be nice i know right
we've got we've we've got uh an extra
week of games coming up um this this
fall there's gonna be a week 18
um which is going to be something uh
wild to get to before another
you know
extra wild card game per wild card day
this
this coming january middle of january
it's going to be a little bit weird to
get to get used to but uh i am
particularly fired up to work with you
and kurt and who you call the games with
um
hosting the monday night football
broadcast from probably this position
right here
in my office uh it is just such an um
you know
it is truly amazing kevin that monday
night football
is still in so many ways
three words that carry with it a special
message and a special feeling to it
after all these years a half century in
kevin you know i i'm so glad you said
that i i feel the same way when i first
took an interest in radio it was
probably back about
1972 73 74.
i was 12 13 years old and i remember
listening to monday night games
i believe at that time they were on
mutual broadcasting and i think lindsey
nelson was one of the voices of monday
night football on radio
and then uh it went to a whole new level
when jack buck and hank stram were
broadcasting and i remember driving when
i was in high school
for maybe games that i had done or
covering a practice
uh but just just uh you know in high
school and thinking
would there ever be a way would there
ever in my wildest imagination with an
unlimited ceiling thinking about about
this particular property that i'd ever
get a chance to do monday night football
and so every time i put on that headset
for westwood one regardless of stadium
uh i am i am living a dream and i i do
say a small little prayer of thanks uh
the fact that i've been so incredibly
lucky to to get to do this and
uh i'll i'll let you in on the secret of
all the things i do rich and you may
feel this way after you join us this
year it's it's the most fun the most
fulfilling the most challenging thing
that i do i i get such
incredible satisfaction being a part of
that broadcast
well i mean there's so many different
ways to go based on the answer you just
gave so i'm going to kind of take it one
step at a time here
uh you mentioned lindsey nelson for me
uh growing up in new york city
um he was one of the broadcasters of the
new york mets games when i was a kid
and the thing that just leaps out to me
about lindsey nelson
is i never thought that jackets could
look like that the ones that he would
wear
it looked like a horse blanket you know
like i i they were just these wild plaid
jackets that he would wear
but he had a set of pipes man that guy
had a set of pipes from genesis i think
you i think he was from tennessee may
have even done the volunteers and of
course i think a lot of people
outside of the new york new jersey
connecticut area probably
know him from the notre dame
college football rewinds on
on sunday morning that were syndicated
all over the country
and and and then i watched him with cbs
and actually
um
uh
i don't want to get too far ahead of
myself my dad was with the green bay
packers for 37 years
20 years as the president and ceo when i
was in grade school in high school
i used to spot
in the lambeau field press box
for different broadcasters and networks
and got to work a couple times with
lindsay nelson uh spotting spotting for
him and it was just the thrill of a
lifetime kidding now again that's
another part of your answer because
you'd mention you were
you know 12 and listening to the radio
and hearing lindsey nelson and you were
inspired to get into
radio but also part of your upbringing
that some
might not know you just mentioned you
were exposed
to the world of the nfl
right from the get-go
with your dad being such an important
part
of the packers organization and being at
the forefront
of the packers organization is
in terms of the lead member of
membership as they call it in the
national football league what what is
your first
football memory
i'll go back rich even before that my
dad was with the baseball cardinals as
their media relations director during
the time of the two world series and 67
against the red sox and in 68 against
denny mclean and mickey lowich and the
detroit uh tigers al kaylin mcauliffe
all those all those
yeahs with the red sox but on that
cardinal team and i used to go to spring
training
for two weeks every year that he was
with the cardinals from 65 to 71 bob
gibson lou brock kurt flood roger maris
julian javier tim mccarver
orlando cepeda i mean like all these
incredible
baseball players at bush at a brand new
bush stadium in st louis my dad had been
with al mcguire at marquette as the
sports information director and then
went to the baseball cardinals in 65
and so when i was a kid we would go to
church on sunday mornings drive after
church down to busch stadium in st louis
have breakfast in the press box and i
remember distinctly walking in here
would come jack buck and he would see me
and my dad having breakfast in the press
box and i was like six seven years old
uh here came vin scully and and um
bob prince of the pittsburgh pirates
like these incredible voices um and and
then on those sundays when i would watch
home cardinal games from uh the box
seats or go out to left field or sneak
into the clubhouse or wherever i was um
it put me like behind the curtain i got
to see press boxes and fields and
practices and all kinds of things and
when dan devine
left the university of missouri in 1971
he took my dad with him to run the
packer front office so i was a ball boy
from 1971
into the times i got in college in green
bay and then during the games go to the
press box and spot work on stats or do
whatever so i got to see everything and
it just put me uh so much further ahead
because i knew the mechanics i was i was
lucky enough to be exposed to all these
great writers the way a press box
operated the way a broadcast
booth moved and and that just fueled the
the fire even more
that is amazing kevin all right again
i i i just want to rewind a little bit
here
because i did not know that part about
your father's history he was the sid for
al mcguire marquette are you serious
does he you got a good you got a good
story from your dad about that about al
mcguire and marquette i've got a pretty
good one broadcast related when i was
young they've got a picture of me
on a court with a ball and
it shot from my back and in the
background al mcguire is having a
practice with his marquette then
marquette warrior basketball team this
is 1964
63 i was three four years old
fast forward to cbs where i worked now
and have for the last 24 years al
mcguire and i worked on a game together
at michigan state
um
and
i brought that picture
and we put it on the air of i was three
or four
and al mcguire's conducting practice
in in the background and al mcguire when
my dad rejoined the packers who came
back to wisconsin and read and joined
the packers um would come up on his
harley-davidson motorcycle from
milwaukee to attend one
training camp practice every year
and you know i saw him all through high
school he come up once a year and by
himself and take off the helmet here was
al mcguire and he'd watch practice and
get back on the harley and drive back
down to milwaukee
he was he was a character and a
wonderful guy and just uh so i've kind
of known him in three different ways
when i was a kid in in three or four
when i was in high school and he'd come
to practice and then uh when i
one time i worked with him at cbs which
was a treat and it was the second to
last broadcast al ever had the last one
was with uh
dick enberg the late dick enberg and
billy backer cbs got him together the
week after we did a game and that was
his final game at cbs no kidding
wow i mean talk about life working that
way kevin that is amazing i did not know
that
and that's part of the thing i love
about this podcast series is just i love
talking about announcers and
broadcasting and and you know enberg and
and and obviously mcguire and packer
were
one of the greatest trios to call any
sporting event for any sport
as well and i had no idea that you were
exposed to all of that
um at such a young age so
how did you get your first break because
obviously you know your father and your
your life you you were afforded to get
in on um
in spots that you know uh exposed you
and and stoked your interest in anything
how did you get your first gig how did
you eventually work into that before you
asked about my first football memory and
my first football memory was more of a
voice and the voice was john fasenda of
nfl films as he narrated super bowl one
between the packers and the chiefs
and and that kind of uh perk my interest
in in voice in football and sports and
broadcasting
when i was a ball boy from time was
about 11 until i went to college
i worked all the summers and during my
lunch break i would run up to the press
box in an empty
lambo field
and go in the packer radio network
broadcast booth shut the door and do
imaginary games on the field and then in
my room
uh in green bay growing up shut the door
turn on the tv turn down the sound and
did countless games
off of television
i went to a high school in green bay
that that
unbelievably ran a radio station run by
students it was a 10 watt radio station
and tried out for the play-by-play job
which i had been practicing for the
previous three or four years
in my room by myself or in an empty
lambo uh field up in the press box
and got the job when i was a sophomore
and and did play-by-play from 15 years
on
uh
through high school sophomore junior and
senior year football basketball hockey
soccer um
and track meets
and then i got to the point where i was
then freelancing and doing games on
commercial radio stations in high school
up and down the fox river valley which
included oshkosh and manitowoc and
sheboygan and all these all these little
cities north of and south of green bay
um and and then went to college and like
so many of us i really got my teeth into
the business at that time with
journalism classes and and some
practical experience with the student
station and commercial stations at the
university of kansas that's about to say
so you're a jayhawk right okay
all right and who was uh who was
coaching then and or playing there then
well um
don fambro was the football coach you
wouldn't know him but the basketball
coach with ted owens
but but even more interesting than that
the the guy that that gary bender of cbs
had recommended to my dad
um that i look at kansas i was going to
go to wisconsin and be in their
journalism department and bob johnson
the hockey coach of the badgers was
recruiting a couple of our players on
our high school team was in our
broadcast area as i was doing a hockey
game and offered me a scholarship
through the hockey program to go to
wisconsin to broadcast hockey
for the badgers and of course they had
olympians on that team eventually that
went out and played in uh
in the 1980 olympics so so um anyway but
but but uh including his son mark john
um so anyway um
uh uh gary bender who told my dad i said
you should go to kansas and there's a
guy that broadcasts the jayhawks does
the football basketball by the name of
tom hedrick
um and i went down there visited with
with tom hedrick and he said if you come
to ku i'll let you be with me on the
jayhawk network on football basketball
doing our pregame
time in post game you can do sideline
and football on the network i'm on the
net
i was sold
and ironically enough
tom hedrick
was the first voice
of super bowl one on cbs radio with jack
dries a chicago broadcaster and tom did
super bowl one and super bowl four
and uh ironically enough then i did
super bowl 50. so you talked moments ago
about things going full circle i mean
how weird
is that that he would uh be kind of my
mentor for those four years at kansas
and then like him i would do the super
bowl and 50 years after he had done
super bowl one 50 super bowl 55 now and
counting and you know on westwood one
it's i i love stuff like this kevin
harlan so
so what about the
moment
that
you know
that
you knew
i i guess you knew when you were a kid
that this was right for you
but
what about the moment when you realized
it was work though right i mean like
that there is preparation that goes into
it and travel and things like that
was that in college did at any moment in
time you wonder if this was something
you
wanted to continue to do or it was
always
um a labor of love from the get-go
always been a labor of love um i i
always tell people um
uh that i am uh living the life that i
dreamt of living and i always dreamt of
of doing games especially on on radio
network radio is my first love my true
love right now in terms of the business
and
and and what i find the most challenging
we can talk about the we can get in the
weeds on that a little bit later on
because i know you like some of those
mechanical things but i
um
i think it became work once i met my
wife i had
uh my first job out of college was in
the nba doing the kansas city kings on
radio and television i worked with easy
ed mcauley on tv but on radio i worked
by myself for 60 games did 22 with him
on a simulcast and then the other games
are just radio and i did those by myself
but i got that job the day i graduated
from kansas i was 21 when i got it
started when i was 22
in the nba did two years with the kings
before they moved to sacramento and as
they were
trying to get me to go to sacramento to
continue as their voice the chief's job
opened up on radio
and i wanted to stay in kansas city
anyway all my buddies were there i was
still single i knew i knew the city i
knew the area so well loved kansas
and and got the chiefs job
hired by lamar hunt on a football
on a football shape table that was
probably 10 yards long and he was at one
he was at one tip of the table lamar
hunt and i was at the other and bob
springer you may remember that name the
long time pr director for the chiefs was
sitting to my right and the president of
the team jack stem it was just the four
of us in this room
and he offered me the job at 24 to do
the to do the chiefs and i did them for
nine years but i met my wife i need i
need i need i need more information even
though you told me
so
so so you get through i imagine the
vetting process long enough where like
you've got to meet mr hunt right that
that's the way it went len dawson and i
had to do the missouri football spring
game that previous saturday at arrowhead
so i had flown home from doing the kings
at the spurs on tv flew home saturday
morning went right from the kansas city
airport to arrowhead and walk in the
booth and here is hall of famer len
dawson on a saturday an off day for him
and we're going to tape the first half
of this game that then lamar hunt
subsequently listened to and hired me
off that off that that spring football
game for the missouri tigers but when i
met my wife and began to travel yes when
it became work that's when it became
work when i had to travel that when i
had to leave her and we have a family
four three girls and a boy and that's
when that's when it became hard and i
felt like it became like work because of
the travel and being away from home yeah
i mean i i you know growing up kevin um
my guy who in new york city who made me
fall in love
with the concept of of doing this was
marv albert
um growing up listening to
the knicks
and the rangers on the radio and marv
calling it and then
you know when i was old enough to stay
up
you know snapped off the radio and then
tuned into wnbc
tv and watched marv do
the sports and i'm like so
wait a minute i'm like so he's in
madison square garden
calling the knicks and the rangers and
then he
you know goes to work after that
on tv
she calls the game then he does the the
highlights i'm like
this is the greatest thing ever
and in the same way that you would call
games bless you and you know
in an empty lambeau field i was on
harold street in staten island new york
realizing i couldn't hit the curveball
so i might as well call the matches of
my brother you know and
that's what i would do
and um
i just
fell and i read marv's book
something along the lines of you know
sorry but i have a game you know i'd
love to but i've got a game i think
that's it correct i'd love to but i've
got a game and that was the first time i
did realize as a growing up like okay
it's a job you know and it is a dream
job and but it is you know
it's something you know and um and it's
that's why i just was wondering because
it's a dream way to grow up and get
exposed to it and then work your ass off
to get to the position where where you
were
but it's interesting so then you you met
your wife and you had kids and then you
know
sorry i'd like to but i have a game i'm
sure that happened it happened a lot
i've i i think we've been married for 34
years i think i've been around for like
three anniversaries
i've missed a lot of birthdays but what
the kids
would tell you and i and i it's it's
it's funny we're talking about this nfl
films has been here for two straight
days filming
a story on our family
my daughter uh was with espn uh he's
done a lot of sideline work works with
westwood one on occasion doing sideline
my dad was with the packers and me and
my nfl career uh with my uh 30 i think
it's my 37th consecutive season doing
the nfl uh play-by-play
um but but we were talking about
about uh you know i said i said i
i always worried that i wasn't if the
kids
if the remembrance
of me when they were growing up was of a
dad that was not there and they said
that was
by the grace of god they said this they
said it was
that was the furthest thing from my mind
you were there every time we had a game
every time we were cheerleading and i
and i and there were some interesting
you know flights back and forth we'd do
team meetings in the morning i'd fly
back on friday afternoon watch them
cheer or play on friday night and get
back on a plane saturday and go back to
our city and do our stuff and sometimes
um you know have been there for for the
important things and we would just
rearrange birthday instead of on a
tuesday we'd celebrate it on a wednesday
and if my wife and i had an anniversary
on a wednesday we'd celebrate it maybe
on a thursday when i was home um but but
i'm off in the summer i'm off right now
i'm at our uh i'm i'm off right now
except for some packer preseason
broadcast but i've been off since the
middle of june when the nba time in the
nba stopped so i think they but but but
every time it's been harder and every
time i get on that plane
and you probably realize this too just
you know you
when you're away from home you're away
from home and it just isn't as
comfortable we've all got a job to do
certainly and that's part of life but it
doesn't make it any easier and that that
becomes the hardest part the prep i i
never find the prep is hard i i not that
i enjoy the process enberg always said
uh to us in our cbs seminars he would
say uh what i enjoy the most is digging
into the books and writing down the
notes and i don't feel that way at all
i mean i like my i like oh my
and by the way dick enberg i mean and
you know you knew him and yeah
what a uh just wonderful insight into
the business and being being a dad and
being a husband and just just just
a man in full right i mean he
he was a wine connoisseur he traveled
the world he did olympics he did
everything but um
but but i i enjoy
um my satisfaction comes after a game or
after a play or a quarter when i said
boy you know what i think i did that and
and the most anguish comes
when um i feel like i wish i would have
used this word or use that phrase or
figure out a way how i could have called
that better or laid out more or talk
more or whatever and you always have you
get in a car after game heading to the
airport you feel like there are a
thousand different things you would have
done differently but um it's live tv or
live radio and right and that's what
makes it challenging and the challenge
is accepted by everybody that's there
and i i love the challenge and that
that's probably the most gratifying but
that becomes the work just making sure
that you're on top and staying focused
and doing your job
well as we matriculate our way through
this interview to use the uh hank stram
phrase here um so 37 years ago your
first broadcast was what the nfl give me
your first game your first your first
assignment your first uh partner in the
booth walk me through it kevin well the
first uh first nfl play-by-play job
1985.
preseason game in cincinnati with len
dawson and an old time broadcast at the
late bill grigsby who did the first year
the chiefs were in kansas city in 1963
and that was my first nfl broadcast now
to backpedal a little bit while i was in
college doing all these other games on
sunday i produced
uh i produced the chiefs pre-game show
on kcmo radio and news talk station they
hired me when i was a sophomore in
college they gave me three hours of a
pregame show to produce
so i was
involved in the broadcast when i was
about 19 years old
and commuting into kansas city from the
lawrence campus
and and doing all these all these
different things for this three hour
pregame show the best part of it though
rich i mentioned john fasenda earlier on
and that was the voice that really got
me thinking about about broadcasting
when i was eight nine years old
um
uh i wanted for cena to do the open to
the show
and i i i wrote a note to nfl films to
john fasenda uh like in 1980 1979
and i said what i was doing and i'd love
him to here's the copy
here's the address
please add your invoice
i'd be most grateful if you do this and
about a week goes by and i get at my
fraternity
in college at the university of kansas
this nfl films package and in there are
the reels from john fasenda
and and um
um
and he put his phone he said call me
when you get this i didn't even listen
to him i called him and said hi mr
fasenda this is it and he said let me
ask you a question kevin
would you mind if i re-voiced one
portion of this
tape and i said sure do whatever you
want
thank you kevin i'm in the studio now
and i'll i'll send this to you pronto
and so
sure enough a couple days later here
comes the second reel that fascenda has
has recorded everything again but he has
added his own touches and i'm listening
to the tape then uh later that week for
the first game
and i'm listening to the raw tape and
facet is on there saying uh boys let's
try saying this this this and he records
whatever he he says and the way he wants
it to be read and he goes
now that's a horse that i can ride and i
did i could just see
john pasenda in that voice saying that
and and then and i've got the tape
somewhere in my home in kansas city and
um but that that just again brought
things full circle of the great
legendary voice who got the pete roselle
award this year into the hall of fame
in canton uh
john vicente's voice um and and he uh he
recorded that for me when i was in
college for our show
oh my gosh two stories i got to tell you
based off of this one
when fasenda um was named the recipient
of the roselle award which goes to
somebody of a distinguished
career in broadcasting uh that's the
that's how they a broadcaster goes in
the pro football hall of fame for those
who may not know
um i called up nfl films um
and um i i poked around there i spoke to
ken rogers who's one of the you know
long time producers there and i'm like
you know who there can get give me uh
the best for senda story
you know
and he turned me on to greg cosell who's
been there for over 30 something years
the nephew of howard but who's been
there forever and a day and he told me
that his tenure started just at the end
of facenda
and that he would write some copy
and you know drive it over sometimes to
fasenda's house to have him
record it or
have him
he'd walk it into the studio with him
and when he got copy that he
particularly liked
he would turn to
greg and he would say now that's a horse
i can ride
how about that how about that what he
said according to greg cosell when he
got copy that he really liked now that's
a horse i can ride so when you said that
i'm like oh my god that's what greg
cosell just told me
it's a fascenda line so you got the
highest praise
you could have gotten from john fasenda
which i'm thrilled to be able to even
remotely tell you
um
i love that the other one is the reason
why i was you know calling around to nfl
films to ask for a name is because
obviously
when he was alive the person you'd reach
out to is steve sable
cause you know i and i miss steve
immensely who went into the hall of fame
posthumously and a year late because he
was part of the 2020 centennial class he
just went in
that
he
steve
was the walking encyclopedia he was the
walk he he was he was nfl films
incarnate he was the hall of fame in nfl
films walking around his brain was one
of the most beautiful brains and it's so
remarkably
heart wrenching that it was his brain
that eventually
um did him in
but the reason why i bring this up is i
asked for send i mean i asked
sable
in the first interview i ever conducted
with him
at the super bowl in houston in 2004
calendar year 2003 season the first one
we ever did for nfl network
um that was the uh the the um patriots
beating
jake deloam john fox in the carolina
panthers
i asked him
the
person that nfl films had to bleep out
the most
in the history of nfl films
and his answer shocked me he said marv
levy
and i'm like the i've yes i'm like the
ivy league coach of the bills and
obviously the chiefs as well
and yes that marv cursed like a sailor
he said sometimes it was sounding like a
truck backing up
we finished the interview on the air and
i turned him i'm like i can't believe
it's marv levy you had to bleep out the
most
and he says to me well
i do have some outtakes of john fasenda
that you'd really blow your mind
and i'm like what
really
like john fasenda would be the autumn
wind as a uh like f that like i'm like
really like he
he said yes
and i'm like is there any way
i could hear one of them
and he said never it will never see the
light of day so somewhere in mount
laurel new jersey that reel exists kevin
and i would let me tell you two things
you've talked about when i was doing the
chiefs
um cbs had just lost the rights to the
nfc fox had gotten them we're in buffalo
afc championship game joe montana
quarterbacking the chiefs i've just
finished interviewing marty
schottenheimer for our network coaches
show i'm walking down
the tunnel the ramp onto the field
walking across the field and i see
that i'm going to intersect with carl
peterson the president general manager
of the chiefs and his best friend
steve sable and as i'm approaching carl
gets this big smile on his face and i
think okay you know i'm clearing my
hello you know get ready to say hello
and uh carl goes we were just talking
about you steve was telling me a story
about you
and i said hello i'm kevin goes i know
who you are you know steve i'm like a
big smile on his face he said fox just
called me this week they said give me
the top three play-by-play guys in your
opinion doing radio in the nfl for local
markets
and i gave him your name
and so every year
that i sign a contract renewal with ben
fox and then for the last 24 years cbs
while he was alive i wrote a note to
steve sable saying the only reason i'm
at this level is because of your
kindness your generosity your
thoughtfulness and putting my name in
front of somebody who could hire and
i'll forever be thankful
and then um you know so obviously we've
gotta we've got a connection there you
mentioned fasenda before every game i'm
going to pull this up before every game
i broadcast
because fasenda was my first
real
voice that that captured my imagination
i play this before every sunday game
when i leave my hotel room for cbs and
every monday night
before i go to our field to do our
monday night i won't get too emotional
here but when i hear that it just it
just it puts me
in the in the frame of mind of of doing
the nfl how lucky i know you feel this
way is the as is really the voice now of
the nfl we all feel so lucky
and privileged to be a part of this
great thing
and when i think of my football weekends
and one day with cbs and one day with
westwood one and one day working with
trent green then kurt warner and now you
um
these these are these are um you know
this is those are the things that now
for me at this stage of my career that i
appreciate the most
and and just to i guess tie it all
together that um that
that reading of the autumn wind um
about the the raiders is a poem that
steve sable wrote he wrote that
so he wrote it and for senda that was a
horse that fasenda could ride i'm sure
when he got that copy
and um it is
you know sable i get emotional talking
about it um and i love sharing these
stories um certainly with people who
revere him
as i you clearly do
um i i wrote a book in 2007 about the
launch of nfl network i don't know what
compelled me to write a book but i did
and it was it was an undertaking man to
say the least and you could get it in
like it's probably in one of these
shelves behind me somewhere uh you could
get it for a cent somewhere um i'm gonna
download it tonight on my kindle yeah
you please you it it's great man uh it's
it's a little dated it's about the you
know the the weekend nfl draft and
things like that you know it's it's
dated there's so much has changed it's
remarkable it's changed between 2007 and
now 2021
but um uh there was a no-brainer for the
person to write the forward it was steve
sable
so i called steve sable up and i'm like
look you know i'd love for you i'm sure
you you've got a lot of requests for
this sort of stuff but uh you know the
nfl network doesn't exist without you
you are the
the the grand poobah of everything that
is nfl media which it wasn't even called
at the time but
uh i i i'm like hey if you could find
the time to write a forward you know
what and and anytime in the next you
know a few weeks please do it and if
anybody's ever asked anybody to do
anything in our industry you know it's
it's sometimes they'll you know you got
to ask again or you'll follow up put it
down the very last moment and then send
it in kevin within
three days in the mail
i got the most remarkable
um forward that included you know
references to howdy duty you know like
typical steve sable like i don't know
how he could
why he would use that to talk about the
invent the advent of nfl network or me
and it was everything i wanted and more
and um it's something i will always
cherish
and that family you know is a reason why
nfl network exists and i love hearing
that you think of him before you do
every broadcast um it's it's so it's so
cool man i'm so glad that we're telling
these stories to each other and for this
audience right now and
so um um you know i'm glad we got a
chance to talk about steve it's
basically what i'm saying
so
he's had this uh wonderful place now in
uh and canton with his dad
and um and how how wonderful is that
that the sable name is as
prominent in that wing of canton as
well look man obviously you and your dad
um are
our seminal names for for the nfl in
terms of uh front office work and and
you know being at the forefront of a
franchise and you being a voice
of the nfl for uh locally and nationally
now 37 years so um
who was your what was your first game
for cbs where you earned your jacket i
guess your sport coat i remember my
first game for fox my first network game
for fox okay so fox you were on fox
before cbs i was for four years in fact
they hired you know they hired summer
all and they hired stockton
and then they they probably had no more
money left to spend so
so they hired four other guys they hired
me
joe buck
kenny albert and tom brennaman and we
were there six play-by-play guys and my
first and four-year partner my first
partner only partner for your partner
was jerry glanville
and our first game was at lambeau field
in green bay
uh with the vikings playing the packers
and um they come on with james brown who
at that time was with fox
and he said welcome to a new dawn of nfl
broadcasting
on fox sports and he's there with jimmy
and terry and and howie and everybody
else
and they're a minute or two into their
pregame show first time they broadcast
the nfl
and their first stop
on the road was in green bay because
sterling sharp was holding out of
practice
and games leading up to the opener
because he didn't like his contract and
that was the big story opening weekend
1994
and they came to to me at lambeau then
they widened the shot to me and jerry we
gave him the report we're not five
minutes as a network into the nfl and i
send it back to los angeles another fun
moment my brother brian was with the
chicago bears uh for 16 years he was
there with ditka and mcmahon in the
fridge walter he yes he was the pr
director with kenny valdiserri and he
was there for 16 years in chicago and uh
we would do this whip around on fox
where uh summer all would send it to so
and so and and buck would send it to
brennaman and brennaman would send it to
dick stockton and stockton you know so
we would do this whip around all the
games they were going to broadcast
in that early window so pat summerhall
is giving his report uh this may have
been like week two
and and i'm pat summerall in san
francisco now let's go to brian harlan
at soldier field in chicago he was
throwing into my he got mixed up with
with my brother and me
and felt horribly and called me that
night and he felt horrible i said please
just hearing you say our last name is
enough and and
and i use pat sumrall's spotting boards
to this day
when i was a couple years at fox uh i i
was
we were talking about preparation and
summer all said what do your boards look
like and i said uh well i've got him
kind of positionally
depicted i've got the offensive line
i've got the receivers they got a tied
in i got the backs and i got the
quarterback goes
he goes let me bring my boards next week
and i'll show you
and he brought his boards
and i have used him ever since um
because he does him numerically and in
this day and age rich as you know with
players now wearing number 11 and number
six and they're playing defensive line
in the nfl or lineman going back in
coverage the sub packages they're all
over the place so numerically has been a
gift from pat sumrall that i use to this
day with my with my spotting boards well
in this year as you know the players are
allowed to wear all sorts of numbers
like that's going to come in really
handy this year it is and i i just
finished doing a game um my first
preseason game at the packer television
network and we got guys were in single
digits playing linebacker playing
defensive line and it's it's running
backs now with the single digit which
you never saw now you do and now you
know that that just because you see a
number 49 does not mean a guy you know
should be in this place now he could be
who knows where
and uh or number eight or number 11. so
it's it's weird it's going to take some
it's it's a good it's going to be tough
on play-by-play guys i know
how about that kevin so you're you you
listen to fasenda before a broadcast you
look down you see summerall's boards i
mean my gosh you're a walk-in museum
you're a walk-in broadcasting museum
when you're doing this thing it's
incredible
i know
you're guided by those kinds of people
that the voices
in your head are the people that whether
it's musburger you know the greats that
have hosted they've been the hosts of
these
magnificent sundays in pro football and
and those are the voices i hear in my
head i i wish i sounded more like them i
don't but i but i do i do hear those
voices
and and i'm sure you do too like like
we're all guided by people like you were
talking about lindsey and us we're all
we're all following that compass that
those earlier broadcasters set for us to
follow and i i do every sunday and
monday night for sure for sure well
kevin let's wrap it up with the question
i ask everybody on this series and that
is the best piece of advice and from
whom that you've received in your
broadcasting career what's the
best words of wisdom you've received who
who told it to you and
lay it on me i think i've got a pretty
good one when i was doing the kings and
i was 22 doing the nba i was doing a
game
uh in landover maryland with the kansas
city kings against the washington
bullets before going before going to
that game when i was in college i
listened to larry king do overnight on
mutual broadcasting i thought he was the
best interviewer i had heard i loved his
voice
he was a an economy of words an
efficient just i just i just idolized
larry king
and i had called the offices of mutual
in crystal city virginia and i said
here's who i am here's what i've done
here's what i've listened to growing up
would you mind after i do this game if i
drove to crystal city from landover to
watch larry king do his overnight show
and they said sure
so i drive in
after the game from land over in a
rental car get the crystal they let me
in i'd go to the and king's show has
already started and i'm sitting in a
booth where i can see him through the
glass and that night his interviewer and
his interviewee was john mccain
talking about being a prisoner of war
so john mccain and larry king are in
there talking for a couple hours they're
taking calls
john mccain leaves
um we now get into the last hour of his
show between 4 am and 5 am but i cannot
take my eyes off of larry king and he
comes into the booth during a commercial
break and he says uh hi
uh they said we had a what do you call
us a uh uh not a i'll think of it here
in a second um we said we had a young
broadcaster in here and i'll think i'll
think of the term he used a fi fire oh i
forget what it was and he goes it goes
how are you and i knew i had just a
limited time so i said do you have any
advice for a young broadcaster who's
just starting
and he said yeah the advice i would tell
you is
always please yourself he says you're
going to have
different people in your ear you're
going to have producers you're going to
have directors you're going to have
bosses and program directors and
everybody telling you how you should do
it and what you should say and how you
should sound and everything else
he said but the advice i would give any
young fireballer i think is what maybe
was that what it was
what i would recommend
is always
please yourself because if you always
please yourself you'll stay true to
yourself and in this business as you'll
find the longer you're in it you need to
stay true to yourself believe what you
believe in
study the others do all the things
you've got to do to be good
there's a road map out there and i'm
saying you know follow that but but at
the end of the day you've got to please
yourself so
when i talk to college kids they tell
them that i say be present i said in
this business if you're wishing you were
this person or envious of that person or
trying to be like him or trying to be
like whatever i said you're not being
yourself and you're not doing the job in
front of you if you're looking over here
and over here or up there over there
you're not looking right in front of you
and the biggest problem we have in this
business the higher you go in it is
being envious of this job assignment or
where this guy is on the totem pole or
what this guy is doing and what you're
not doing how much money this person's
making and what you're not making
just be thankful you're doing compute
there are thousands that are lined up to
do what you're doing be thankful don't
be envious be thankful and and that is
that is how i am i am uh i have enough i
am so thankful that i have been lucky
enough to be in this business and to to
literally this point and i'm talking
with someone who i've admired forever
have followed your career i'm gonna be
your teammate and so these
this is why i am thankful that i'm in
this business
ron and right back at you and and
clearly you take uh larry king's advice
to heart even to this day as i could
hear it um as you call um
nfl games and you call
uh big moments and games uh with the
same enjoyment as you do streakers on
the field kevin so
you're clearly having fun
what i would love to do is call your 40
time at the combine for st jude that's
what i want to do and next year kevin i
i you know let's do it let's let's let's
get on and i'll get i'll get people to
to and i'll think of weird stuff to say
and i'll and i'll and i'll do something
for for nfl network and and we'll get
that on because that cause um
if if there's a cause to believe in
thank you that that is a cause is a
cause to believe in
well i just hope that your call is less
than six seconds
oh there'll be a there'll be a preamble
there'll be the call
and then they'll be the afterword and
that will be the fun part to call
huffing and puffing and striding look at
him go oh galloping his way we could
have so much fun with that let's
please let me do that don't ask anybody
please
no don't worry it's in you're locked in
it's done
the job's yours kevin that's a horse i
can ride i'm a horse you can ride amen
this is great this is great kevin thank
you for being on just getting started
and uh this whole season on westwood won
a total blast look forward to can't wait
thank you so much an honor to be with
you my privilege to be joining you on
this podcast thank you rich what a fun
episode with kevin harlan i mean what a
lush
lush story
from the way he grew up and what his
father
did for a living and how he got exposed
to that and then making the most of his
opportunities again i think that's what
we're beginning to see here is the
opportunities that have been afforded
to
uh our guests but it's what you do with
them you know that'll only take you so
far
and i just also love the piece of advice
that kevin harland got from larry king
and it may come across certainly in an
industry where you know everybody thinks
the talking head it's all about them and
they have an ego and we all have egos i
mean
we don't like to be told that we suck
clearly and that's what you get on
twitter by the way my handle is at rich
eyes and if you want to tell me i suck
i'll just ignore it but please give me a
follow
um
that
it sounds egotistical
that do what interests you
that's what larry king says talk about
the stuff that interests you
and
that is a piece of advice that i totally
understand
certainly since i do a show with my own
name on it
and
it it takes a serious set of uh
you know
a little bit of uh the old what
nicki minaj
cousin's friend
to follow that advice
because there's always a self-doubt like
just because it interests me is it going
to interest a whole bunch of other
people it's called broadcasting for
reason broad
is the root of broadcasting it's not
narrow casting
and that's what we're seeing so much
these days is there's so much narrow
casting that's the way you get your news
you get this you get that
but
trying to reach the largest bunch of
people
to bring you bring them into your tent
to me it takes a set of you know what to
say i'm just going to talk about what
interests me and hope that it interests
other people
that is
one way to look at it the other way i
look at it as well
that it takes a certain confidence level
that you are going to talk about just
the stuff you want to talk about
stuff that interests you if it makes you
happy if it makes you laugh you should
do it
that
you know obviously again broadcasting
you're not just broadcasting for
yourself and your own jollies as i did
to pretty much start my espn
sportscenter career when everything was
a joke and it really wasn't all that
good so you could be dangerous if that's
if that's your
your only mantra or the only way you
look at it
but the reason why
larry king said what he said i believe
is not just to
say the stuff that interests you because
you believe in yourself and that what
you like
you're betting on everybody else is
gonna like too
but what that means is talk about what
you like what makes you happy what makes
you laugh what makes you interested
is another way of saying be genuine
and the most successful people i've met
in
this business and now 25 years of sports
broadcasting or being in the voice
of the nfl world
is being genuine
is a sign of
tremendous success only the most
successful people
have that ability
and
it is so important to be genuine because
every successful person i've met
in this business
on the air
is who they are off the air same person
stuart scott the guy that you saw on the
air sure was he saying these lines catch
phrases and
and citing lyrics and all of that stuff
but that's what he was doing off the air
the silly stuff he was doing on the air
same guy off the air same
person
lights on lights off chris berman same
way same exact way dan patrick keith
olbermann craig kilbourne
you know robin roberts and charlie stein
i mean on and on and on linda
same person
on and off the ear
you know will they have an anchor voice
or something a little bit sometimes when
you're doing you know just trying to
enunciate
same thing michael irvin
dion sanders
over and over again i keep telling you
so
when larry king says talk about the
stuff that you like that interests you
that's you being genuine
you're just saying hey this is what i
believe and let the chips while they
fall where they may
you know
and that's the my mantra going about my
job every day on
the rich eisen show
again
it's fun to refer to a name with my own
name in it which sounds egotistical but
that's the name of it you know
um
is that i'm gonna talk about the stuff
that interests me talk about my life
best i can about my
wife who sits in for me my wife susie
fills in and
i love that
talk about my kids talk about movies
talk about tv shows and then my opinions
about the nfl and sports in general
and let the chips fall where they may
i'm being genuine literally
um saying stuff on the air that i would
say off the air
and i think that's what larry king was
telling
kevin harlan
um that there's two ways of looking at
it like i said one is you got to have
the confidence and belief itself
to talk about stuff
that you think the rest of the world
likes and
and and in that regard in the nfl
network on the nfl network on the air
when i'm hosting a draft or a combine or
game day morning on a sunday this fall
as i do every sunday from
9 00
a.m eastern to kickoff of little one
o'clock games
on the eastern time zone that i'll
always ask the questions that i think
fans have either called into my show to
ask me or i think fans are most
interested in try to put myself in the
fan shoes
so
that's my way of broadcasting but i'm
also interested in the answer to the
question myself because i consider
myself a fan
and then the other part of looking at it
again is
is to you know
make sure you're genuine
literally asking questions that i'm
concerned about myself
and also reacting to the guys on the air
in the same way that i would in a
meeting or
you know
in an airport terminal waiting for the
same flight to take us somewhere
pre-pandemic
so
great piece of advice right there from
larry king to kevin hall that's not a
name i was expecting during this series
of podcasts although larry used to be a
voice of the nfl he worked on the miami
dolphins broadcast
way back in the day